finding work in the Gaza Strip has
become a struggle for many there are few
jobs and the economy is stagnant
it's worsening the living conditions of
hundreds of thousands of Palestinians we
summon nahal and his six family members
live in one bedroom their main source of
income is coin that they boil and sell
on the Gaza sea Cornish
says he has been looking for work for
years
I tried to find a job in both the
private and public sectors but without
success the number of people here is
increasing but there are no job
opportunities
really restrictions are the entry of
products as well as the closure of
Crossings have resulted in significant
financial losses
used to run a thriving textile Factory
but because of the blockade he's had to
reduce operations and the number of
Staff he employs
in the past this Factory had 300 workers
we used to export to Israel and the rest
of the world but because of the
restrictions and violence it is barely
running now he's not the only one
hundreds of people in Gaza have been
suspended from their jobs because of the
dire economic conditions and they add to
thousands already unable to find work to
provide for their families
the effects are visible throughout the
Gaza Strip the Palestinian Statics
Bureau says the unemployment rate has
reached worrying levels an estimated 48
in March
this is one of the highest figures in
the world Youth and employment is even
higher topping 64 percent
73 percent of the Gaza graduates with no
jobs
although they are professional and good
but there is zero opportunities in the
Gaza Market
but out from the Palestinian economy
Ministry shows more than 90 percent of
employees in the private sector earn
less than the Gaza minimum wage of 190
dollars a month
in addition the prices of goods and
basic Commodities have increased sharply
in recent months compounding the already
dire humanitarian situation you may see
it Al Jazeera Gaza Strip